i think i'll have the cell phone device
positioned strategically down at the
corner of the laptop and maybe we'll do
some supplemental play-by-play yeah
during the uh during the game itself all
right more total yards chris ben
roethlisberger or rg3 well i i gotta go
with big ben there i mean rg3 hasn't
played football in so long as far as
real competitive game here that means
something for both teams i mean that's a
lot to ask i don't think rg3 is going to
be some slouch out here i don't our g3
can throw the football he has a special
arm i think he's got understanding of
the offense and i think he'll make a few
plays with his legs but
i'm still gonna go with big ben here
yeah look i uh
i don't disagree with that although you
just never know what's gonna happen with
uh with rg3 and that offense and yeah
you know you you you reminded me of what
happened in week 8 265 rushing yards and
lamar jackson was part of that so we'll
see but the problem with the ravens
offense has been the involvement of the
receivers i don't think that changes
just because rg3 is on the field if
anything it's going to be even more
challenging they haven't had a lot of
practice time this week i agree with you
it's going to be big ben all right
one thing there too just because of the
stats there like big ben had that you
know really below average first half the
last time second half they kind of
figured out a few ways to attack them
that's gonna be interesting to see too
you know you see there yeah 158 yards
second half two tds was only sacked once
what are the ravens gonna do they gotta
realize yeah our offense might not be as
good without lamar
we can't let really what big ben did at
the end of that game was just play one
on one ball because they're so confused
he just went oh wait this guy's
one-on-one i'll hit you oh he's one on
one i'll hit you and they slowly
matriculated down the football field
that way i would think baltimore's not
going to live on that edge this time
around and play a little differently
who will have the most rushing yards in
the game no james connor he tested
positive last week for covet 19. we do
have mark ingram and jk dobbins back
over unders are benny snell 58 and a
half for the steelers dobbins 41 and a
half for the ravens gus edwards 38 and a
half for the ravens rg 3 28 and have
ingram uh not even on this list because
ingram's kind of fallen out of the
offense anyway this year so who has the
most yards yeah i i i first off i don't
think it's going to be any pittsburgh
running back i know the ravens got no
kaleas campbell and brandon williams
tonight either way but the pittsburgh's
just not a good enough running football
team for me to sit here and take one of
those running backs so for me it goes
between jk dobbins and gus edwards it's
one of those two and those were the two
prime suspects the first time around i
mean it was gus edwards right up the
middle smash your face in okay we'll
fake it to gus edwards here's jk dobbins
on the edge and he'll outrun you i'm
gonna go with gus edwards today this
afternoon i'm gonna take him i'm gonna
take the fact that you know the inside
power running game you know you don't
need a lot of coaching and schematics
and things like that just to blow off
the ball and double team guys and push
them forward i think that could be a
simple way it's a place they have an
advantage and i think it'll be gus
tonight i'm going with him what about
you
i'm going with benny snell i remember
back in whoa when james connor got
banged up benny snell had a big game the
opportunities are few and far between
bang it into the line show what you can
do before a national audience on a
wednesday afternoon but if we know it's
going to be snell
we don't have to guess who it's going to
be like we do with the ravens is it
going to be is it going to be dobbins is
going to be edwards is it going to be
rg3 it's going to be snell he's going to
be the running game and and i i think
that that he will end up having the most
rushing yards you know it's funny we
never go back and hold ourselves
accountable we should tomorrow's game
but tomorrow because usually we do it on
thursday and you're not here on friday
right you'll be here tomorrow yeah let's
pete pete make a note of all these copy
and paste these pete let's remember this
unless we're wrong if we're wrong i
don't want to hear about any of them all
right
which steeler receiver will have the
most receiving yards deontay johnson
juju smith schuster or our guy chase
claypool chris oh
i'm ol johnson is the leader via points
bet 57.5 yards is the over under for
john i think he's more not
the kind of the go-to guy that in the
offense right now the guy that can do
everything so i do think there's a lot
around him i do think the offense and
big ben trust him
this to me comes down to just one thing
who are marlon humphrey and marcus
peters going to cover when all three of
them are on the field how does that work
out because whoever they're not covering
is the guy i want to take right i mean
that's really how i kind of look at it
here
and
i i guess i guess i'm gonna i'm gonna
take chase claypool i am you know that's
my guy you know that i've been riding
hard with him ever since notre dame
football two years ago
i'm gonna say he's gonna get some of
those one-on-one opportunities and to me
one-on-one it's like a dk metcalf yeah
have fun you know roll the dice out and
chase claypool he's he's he's a beast
yeah i i agree with you you can't cover
all three of these guys and somebody's
going to get the opportunities in
claypool the first rookie since the
merger first rookie receiver to have 10
touchdowns in his first 10 career games
and he'll be looking to add to that this
afternoon i keep wanting to say tonight
this afternoon i know it is extending
into early evening leading up to the
lighting of the christmas tree at
rockefeller center on nbc dez bryant
over under now that he's a full-fledged
member of the roster not getting called
up from the practice squad and becoming
you know the 54th or 55th guy on the
roster he's now part of the roster over
under receiving yards 28 and a half
last week he had four catches for 28
yards his first statistics since 2017.
is he going to have more or less than 28
and a half um
i'm gonna say less
i could see him you know flirting with
this number
you know maybe four for 25 something
like that i mean
you know again we know rg3 he can spin
it and throw it certainly but i still
just got to think
you know well no mark andrews that makes
it a little more interesting too but i
gotta still think that
you know guys like snead duvernay
and hollywood brown are going to be
towards the top of the pecking order
before a dez bryant and that's why i'll
just go under there
yeah i uh i'm gonna go over yeah i'm
gonna go over i i think you know dez i
think dez is starting to come around and
uh
um you know it's it's a wild card with a
different quarterback yeah that's right
it could be that rg3 is comfortable with
with dez they've probably known each
other for years they came into the
league at about the same time and maybe
there's a connection there that we don't
quite know about i'm gonna i'm gonna go
ahead and say over on that one pete okay
make it make a note on that one as well
to see which of us is right chris has
the under i
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports